[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to
gamespot's coverage of key 3 20 22
summer game fest whatever you want to
call it we even have t-shirts made up of
k3 so you know we're really rolling with
it and as you can tell we're back in
person again which is why it might be a
little bit louder than usual but that's
all part of the fun we're all here to
get excited about video games i'm lucy
james and joining me is aaron flynn
uh here to talk about nightingale uh
it's great to see you how are you doing
yeah good good lucy thanks how are you
i'm doing well i'm very excited i am i'm
kind of big into sort of fantasy you
know me i
i came to bioware and chatted with you a
few years ago very excited to see what
you've got cooking and nightingale we
saw at the game awards seen it again at
summer game first uh what's it like
being able to kind of put stuff out
there after you know working on things
in secret for a while oh yeah it's great
you know i mean we're getting really
great fan reception when you start
something from scratch and you haven't
you know it's all in your head it's all
in the developers heads you're always a
little bit nervous to put something out
there because you think oh i hope we've
got it right i hope we're doing this
it's what they wanted so it's super
rewarding and gratifying when people get
excited what we're showing and showing
nightingale off and these new things
we're doing here with nightingale so
yeah it feels great actually i think
it's a big relief to get it out there
and see positivity from folks so i we've
we talked a little bit before this
interview but you know what is the
elevator pitch if you had to very
quickly explain nightingale
yeah so nightingale is a survival
crafting game set in a shared world many
you can play with your friends and play
with others and it's in our own ip our
own gaslamp fantasy victorian universe
so that's why you got these cool outfits
and everything but in our game players
get to explore these realms and uncover
mysteries and do things but they also
get to control what realms they go to
thanks to these things called realm
cards because we've built up this really
awesome procedural realm generation
system then players get to play these
cards and control what's on the other
side of portals so they can set the
biome like swamp forest or desert they
can then control other aspects of it and
they have to collect and craft these
realm cards over time share them with
friends do things like that and that
gives them a lot more agency and a lot
more decision making over what they're
going to play and what experience is
going to go all but this really cool fun
a little bit of story through all of it
too i was going to say there was a lot
to unpack there so i want to kick off
with you know you mentioned it's your
own ip um you've got the story threads
bringing you along are you talking like
are you going to give us any little
breadcrumbs about what that could entail
right now like who who am i playing at
yeah that's a good question so you play
as a realm walker and and at the start
of our game um you have gone through a
portal an effort to escape a catastrophe
uh in earth trying to get to the magical
city of nightingale because you figure
that'll be safe there but unfortunately
the portal network has malfunctioned and
you find yourself lost in these in these
deep realms far far away and so the um
the character in our in our trailer
there he is the first to see you and he
says well you're going to need to
survive out here and find a way back to
nightingale at some point so the long
adventure of our game is the realm
walkers finding their way back to
nightingale and all the adventures
they'll have along the way perfect and
so it's not just an adventure that i can
have by myself i can get my friends in
um how how is the multiplayer part of it
is it you know if i'm if i have a
character and then i decide to just kind
of get my friends in for a little bit
how's progress and stuff going to carry
yeah you can certainly do that so we
want to make sure the game is playable
for individuals because it's really
important um but then if you do like to
play with your friends you are welcome
to invite them to your realm and they
can invite you to their realms um and
it's what we call a high trust
cooperative environment by that we mean
you're not going to see other players
around your realm and they're not going
to be able to interact with you unless
you've invited them in unless you've
made that decision which you have a
choice to do um and so you know you can
invite your friends in you can build
together you can you can do things
together you can go adventuring together
and you see some of that in our trailer
when you see multiple realm walkers
running around the assumption is that
you're all friends doing this together
yeah so if there's any griefing
so it's someone that you know and trust
exactly there's any griefing then as we
say get better friends i guess yeah
that's a great way of putting it um so i
guess in terms of you know like
crafting survival there's kind of been
this mini renaissance of it i think
especially everyone's been in covert and
so things like valheim have come along
the rising now where people are
i don't know it's the feeling of
accomplishment what drew you to sort of
that genre yeah it's a great point lucy
you know um there's so many great teams
building survival crafting games with
really interesting innovative mechanics
and ideas there um i think that was very
inspiring for us in our team as we
thought about it um you know we've made
rpgs a lot of us i have too and so we
thought yeah what's an interesting twist
on on a character with a lot of agency a
character and characters who can go do a
lot of things which is at the essence of
a good role-playing game in my opinion
and so survival crafting games offered a
lot of that this notion that you can
construct things and express yourself
creatively you can create gear for
yourselves create buildings for
yourselves and and that just really
really resonated with us early on so a
lot of those mechanics have been in
since the early days of the game and
since becoming inflection studios we
really decided that we would double down
on that and invest in that more fully
and try to bring that experience uh to
the forefront and i was gonna say
another part of it is you kind of have
the showing off part of things where you
know you you meet up with someone you're
like how did you get that yeah exactly
right this notion of of uh acquiring
things and of crafting it yourself and
putting all of that energy and passion
into it and making it just just perfect
for you right the game surrounding
crafting games do such such good things
with that and you get to do all that
knight and kill yeah and so and
nightingale as well i think the thing
that is interesting to me is like you
know valheim you've got and i bring that
up because i played a lot of it with my
friends it's like you have the the sort
of nordic fantasy kind of setting but
then that's the setting right but with
realm cards and in nightingale you have
all of these options for for you as a
developer how
i mean you want to obviously give the
team free reign to experiment and stuff
but how do you also bring that in
oh yeah well i'm lucky to work with a
lot of very talented developers who uh
have some experience in this and who are
pretty good at uh at managing themselves
and doing that um and so i trust them
and work with them and they they provoke
me to come up with things and make sure
that the studio is giving them what they
need to to go off and try these things
um but you know a lot of it's just come
together in the past you know three plus
years of working on this game you know
this notion that we have a tech stack
that lets us assemble and build these
realms procedurally so players are
always getting something a little bit
different a little bit unique
and then this idea that then connecting
that to realm cards as an interface to
controlling what's on the other side of
that just really started to come into
its own recently and i couldn't be more
excited it's so cool to get a chance to
to have a lot of fun in the realm and
then think oh where can we go next and
then you talk to your friends you get
excited about that and then sure enough
you look at your realm card say oh i
could play this one i could play that
one you could play this other one over
here together we go through a portal and
the other side is reflecting exactly
this but still with mystery still with
intrigue still with things discovered
what's the most surprising combination
you've seen
oh some of the uh some of the um some of
the biomes we have uh like desert
combined with some of the fae things
you'll get on the other side it's pretty
cool to see that stuff sitting in the in
the desert is pretty pretty daunting
pretty exciting to see
so you mentioned that it's kind of been
in development for about three and a
half maybe three and a half years since
it was kind of solidified in greenlit
um so i mean how did you bring the team
together and obviously we've been hit by
covid and lockdown
is the team all up in edmonton are you
spread out um yeah a lot of us are
edmonton um a lot of us have either
worked together in the past or we've got
a wonderful crop of younger developers
who've joined us either at a school or
from from a couple years in the industry
we do some remote folks as well and we
continue to hire both in edmonton and
remotely as we want to grow our team but
yeah most of us are in edmonton at a
studio right downtown which is great
and yeah i mean the covid was everybody
returned home and tried to keep
everybody safe working from home there
which we can do in the games industry
it's it's hard at times obviously but
but we are lucky to be able to do that
as compared to some folks who have to be
present you know at a certain facility
for their job
but yeah we've got people back in the
studio now in a hybrid situation and i
think i think it's working out pretty
well and yeah it's nice to see faces
collaborating and seeing each other and
getting excited about things and doing
kind of how i grew up making games which
is you go to someone's desk and look
over that and kind of ask questions
about it and learn in the process too
but hopefully we'll continue that way
for the remainder of the project and
beyond so i mean i know you obviously
came from bioware a lot of the team did
bioware obviously just
master class in storytelling so i was a
bit surprised earlier when you're like
yeah there is story but you know you're
really kind of doubling down on the
gameplay and stuff um but i guess is
that a chance for you to just
flex another another skill another
muscle yeah that's the hope lucy you
know like a bioware game is just such an
investment in storytelling and it
requires a huge team it requires lots of
very specialized skill sets and we never
we never could believe that we could
have uh the team size and the um
and the expertise to do all that so we
wanted to lower our ambitions a little
bit and create a great setting and
create an environment and we really
started to get the idea that it would be
fun to let players create their own
stories right and so how do you give
players more agency how do you give them
just a setting just a sandbox they can
have some fun in and do some things in
where it's unique and special to them
but at the same time they're gonna start
to tell their own stories and and that's
what really striving here to do so
there's a little little breadcrumbs
little little provocations if you will
of storytelling and characters you can
interact with but at the same time the
stories you really want there to be
there are the ones the players make up
and share with each other and say oh
you're never gonna believe what happened
we played these realm cards together
went into this realm it was amazing
perfect well aaron you mentioned to me
earlier it's gonna be people are gonna
be able to play it this year yeah that's
the hope we're working hard the whole
team's working hard so but things look
pretty good lots to do lots of things to
refine but we'll be doing our closed
alpha play test very soon so please sign
up at playnightandgale.com if you're
interested and we will look for you
there awesome thank you so much yeah
thanks lucy much appreciate it yeah of
course and for more on nightingale make
sure to stay tuned to gamespot